okay so this is my own bathhouse Story
the title is and then my skin was rubbed
clean off wait no I got a better title
okay okay
and then he flipped me over
[Music]
okay
in Korea it's uh it's a thing that they
have bath houses it's a thing in many
cultures and in these bath houses you
are naked I've been to them before you
know I've been to them in Korea I've
been to them here in La uh but when I
went to Korea last time my cousin said
something very interesting to me he said
you want massage
wow
and I go I don't mind a massage I like
massage and he goes oh you want massage
and uh I said yes and when we entered
into the bath house we walked past these
two Mass there and there was someone get
s grubbed like someone getting washed
like physically Washed by another person
by another person yeah there was another
person the only non-nude person in this
entire bath house was the person doing
the scrubbing he had shorts on uh so it
was a bit of an oddity but I passed it
by because I was like I know massage is
from the Korean bath house here in La so
we go to the bath house we're so can we
relax and we have a good time and then
my turn comes to get a massage and my
cousin guides me to where the massage is
going and he guides me right to the
tables that the other guy was getting
scrubbed down on and the guy has a scrub
Rag and he flips it over his shoulder a
few times and slaps the bed and he's
like hop up is it the same rag that he
was scrubbing the other person with uh
now that I think about I do not think he
I don't think he changed the wash I just
rang it out dipped it in the bucket it's
fine you smacked the table what do you
think the smacking is for yeah when it
when it when I got up there he got a
bucket of water and he just splooshed it
over the top and you know water ran off
and clean and instantly no problem there
wow so I I lie face down on this table
I'm I'm mortified but I'm like okay
whatever is I'll get over with it's a it
is what it is and this guy like this guy
went at me like he hated me everything
about me everything that I stood for was
writ upon my skin and he needed to
remove it I just remember the most
incredible pain of just shunners the
cheese grater of it and my back was bad
enough you know and he gets every part
of my back top to bottom fully naked
here too right yeah uh so then he says
uh some words to me that I didn't
understand the time now I know he was
your safe word but he's telling me to
flip over but I'm not understanding it
so we kind of like like digs his hand
underneath like my torso and my legs and
he flips me over uh and then he
continues just scrub and I'm like okay
I'm face up naked my Ghibli bits are all
out in the open but you know it is what
it is here we go and he goes just as
hard on my upper of my front and then
when it gets to my legs he does this
what I can only describe is a long
smooth motion that ended with him
pretending like my balls were not there
and he plows from toe to waste
smashing my balls out of the way like
bumper cars
getting in my inner thigh
I can only tell you this guy was
extremely thorough because it took three
impacts to get my whole inner thigh on
one leg before he switches to the other
side oh my God and you'd think he'd
start on the outside I like to give my
balls a break after being smashed to
bits no he starts on the inside on that
side
Same Direction all the way
just full connection I like oh it's just
he didn't give oh [__] so it was over
before I knew it and I swear when I got
up he had a cigarette somehow I don't
know how but he had one was it good for
you this is not even a joke but I only
remembered it afterwards when he was
done
ha